Good morning Hank, it's Wednesday March 21st. I assume you don't want to look at
my eye for the next three minutes so
let's find something else to do.
First we're going to look at these
beautiful pictures that the guide shot
inside the abandoned cathedral, I mean
theater in Detroit. They do a much better
job of showing what it was like to be
inside than the video does. Thanks to the
guide at SNweb.org for these
pictures and finally Hank I've been
thinking of what you should do when
you've had a long day that's kind of
been bad and your eye hurts and it's weepy and gross
and no one wants to be near you and everyone looks at you funny. And it seems to me
that the answer is simple: You just take
stuff and you put it on your head.
Wait, where's the camera? Where am I? Put it on your head. When you're sad and
you've got pink eye the world seems rough and suck levels are high
Just remember there's one thing that you can do and it always works too you gotta
put stuff on your head, put stuff on your head.
Well it can be blue or it can be red. The color doesn't matter if it's on your
head. Attach a photo of Woody right onto your melon or fix a Christmas
stocking to your cerebellum
the only rule of thumb is don't
use a plastic bag because that could go
really wrong.
You got to put stuff on your head, put
stuff on your head.
Well it could be blue or it could be red.
The color doesn't matter if it's on your
head.
Thank you New York. What's on your
head?
Hank, I'll see you tomorrow.